du singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans
une certaine mesure du genre dont deux
sages le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages on a l'impression
qu'on descende des chimpanzés et pas du
tout les chimpanzés nous sommes cousins
germains maternelle qui était bretonne
me disais si toi tu descends du sage
mois seront pas révélées nous un secret
vous en avez mangé du mammouth je me
trouve à fouiller en sibérie et puis un
beau matin dans le trou que j'avais
commencé à creuser je trouve que les
troupes comme c'est quelque chose de
bien les grands filaments je suis
étonnée je râle je dirais que ce sont
des collègues russes qui sont venus
tripatouiller le fond de ma recherche et
puis à force de tirer dessus comme rien
ne venait je me suis aperçu que j'étais
sur le dos tu avais le mammouth
[Musique]
à laâyoune emmanuel macron doit
s'exprimer mardi prochain à 20h sur fond
de d'une reprise de l'épidémie de kovy
d' en france et en europe il s'agit de
faire un point sur la situation
sanitaire notamment à six mois de la
présidentielle une intervention
programmée plusieurs jours après
l'adoption définitive dans les députés
du projet de loi vigilance sanitaire
malgré les réticences du sénat le pass
and i ter qui prolongé jusqu'au 31
juillet
[Musique]
verdict dans la sphère alexandre au
pénal à trois ans d'emprisonnement dont
deux avec sursis pour l'ancien
collaborateur d'emmanuel macron il lui
est également interdit d'exercer dans la
fonction publique pendant cinq ans
l'homme a été poursuivie est notamment
pour avoir commis des violences en
réunion et usurpé la fonction de
policier lors de la manifestation du 1er
mai 2010 800
la coop 26 fête se poursuit à glasgow
jusqu'au 12 novembre et la jeune
militante écologiste greta zone verte a
donné de la voix ce rendez-vous un échec
selon elle la ville écossaise
aujourd'hui où des milliers de jeunes se
sont fait entendre également pour
dénoncer l'inaction des dirigeants
mondiaux à de nouveaux rassemblements
pour le climat sont prévues demain
partout dans le monde
[Musique]
du
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
emmanuel macron fin va donc donné rendez
vous aux français mardi à 20h une
allocution du chef de l'état pour faire
le point sur la crise sanitaire à six
mois de la présidentielle le contexte
sanitaire
qui à nouveau tendue en france et dans
toute l'europe avec une raie pris une
reprise de l'épidémie de covin en
déplacement aujourd'hui à montpellier le
premier ministre jean castex a appelé je
cite à ne pas baisser la garde le nombre
de cas recensés à dépasse le seuil des
5000 depuis le 22 octobre le taux
d'incidence s'élève à 62 soit au dessus
du seuil d'alerté fixé à 20 quand on
écoute le porte-parole du gouvernement
gabriela talent
président de la république prendra à
nouveau la parole évidemment pour faire
un point sur la situation sanitaire au
regard de ce que je viens d'évoquer mais
également un point sur la reprise
économique sur les réformes qui sont
conduites dans notre pays sur l'ensemble
des sujets qui traverse notre pays
aujourd'hui et c'est dans ce contexte
que l'assemblée nationale a adopté ce
vendredi le projet de loi vigilance
sanitaire avec le recours possible aux
passes jusqu'au 31 juillet prochain et
la permission aux chefs d'établissement
de prendre connaissance du statut
vaccinal de leurs élèves les
explications c'est avec thibaut jeanne
le couperet est tombé le projet de loi
baptisé vigilance sanitaire a
définitivement été adopté aujourd'hui
118 députés principalement issus des
rangs de la majorité présidentielle ont
voté pour 89 ont voté contre cet ultime
vote vient mettre un point final aux
discussions autour de ce texte qui a
profondément divisé les deux chambres du
parlement
à deux reprises le palais du luxembourg
s'étaient opposés à la volonté
gouvernementale en proposant un recours
possibles jusqu'en février aucune
conciliation n'a été trouvé entre
sénateurs et députés lors d'une
commission mixte paritaire ce mardi
le dernier mot est revenu à l'assemblée
nationale de quoi faire bondir
l'opposition et notamment nicolas dupont
aignan ce n'est plus une démocratie
ici c'est un palais fantôme c'est plus
une démocratie puisque des députés
abdique leur pouvoir et le pouvoir de
leurs successeurs et le gouvernement va
pouvoir
confiner les français enfermés les
français privés de liberté les français
comme ça sans passer devant le parlement
mais c'est une démocratie ici c'est
ahurissant ce qui vient de se passer et
dans l'indifférence générale
outre les controverses entourant le
processus parlementaire et le pass
sanitaire le projet de loi prévoit
également le durcissement des sanctions
en cas de fraude et la possibilité pour
les établissements scolaires d'avoir
accès au statut vaccinal des élèves des
dispositions jugées sensibles par
certains élus c'est dans un climat
particulièrement houleux que le débat
s'est conclu les réactions n'ont pas
tardé à pleuvoir après l'adoption de ce
texte décrié
nous nous sommes battus jusqu'au bout
contre le pass sanitaire mais la
majorité macro nist et passer en force
ce matin pour le vote définitif
nous restons mobilisés
le parlement en responsabilité a adopté
définitivement le projet de loi
vigilance sanitaire quoique l'épidémie
nous réserve la france aura les moyens
de réagir et de protéger nos concitoyens
les maquereaux nist ont voté les pleins
pouvoirs au gouvernement pour prolonger
le pass annie terre pendant huit mois et
demi liberticide autoritaire
antidémocratique nous saisirons le
conseil constitutionnel dès cet après
midi contre cet énième coup de boutoir à
notre démocratie une opposition qui ne
semble pas avoir dit son dernier mot
certains groupes parlementaires ont
annoncé leur volonté de déposer un
recours devant le conseil
constitutionnel
c'est notamment le cas des groupes
communistes liberté et territoires mais
aussi de la france un souvenir
le verdict aujourd'hui dans la sphère
benalla trois ans de prison dont deux
avec sursis et interdiction d'exercer
dans la fonction publique pendant cinq
ans pour l'ancien chargé de mission à de
l'elysée alexandre benalla poursuivi
pour des violences commises le 1er mai
2018 dans une vidéo on le voyait casques
des forces de l'ordre sur la tête sans
prendre brutalement à des manifestants
s'en était suivi une très vive politique
les prêts les polémiques pardon les
précisions de notre reporter katia
technique depuis à le tribunal
correctionnel de paris
pour les interventions du 1er mai et
autres délié alexandre benalla a été
reconnu coupable notamment de violences
en réunion et immixtion dans la fonction
de policier sa condamnation est plus
lourde que le réquisitoire trois ans
d'emprisonnement dont deux ans assortis
du sursis simple d'aller de prison ferme
sera effectuée au domicile de sa mère il
portera un bracelet électronique
il a en outre interdiction d'exercer un
emploi dans la fonction publique durant
cinq ans il est aussi interdit de port
d'armes durant dix ans ces armes seront
confisquées vincent kraz lui qui était
rattachée au commandement militaire de
l'elysée qui avait été invité par
alexandre benalla à la manifestation a
été condamné à deux ans d'emprisonnement
avec sursis pour lui aussi interdiction
du port d'armes durant dix ans et
confiscation des armes les deux hommes
ont été condamnés également à verser de
fortes sommes aux parties civiles aux
manifestants entre 3000 et 5000 euros
chacun les juges ont estimé que leur
intervention pour interpeller les quatre
manifestants n'étaient en aucun cas
nécessaire et qu'ils avaient commis des
violences illégitimes
les deux policiers qui avaient fourni un
cd-rom alexandre benalla pour cette
défense ce qui constitue une violation
du secret professionnel ont aussi été
condamnés l'un à 5000 euros d'amendé et
le second à trois mois de prison avec
sursis sans inscription au casier je
vous propose d'écouter la réaction du
policier alexandre langlois syndicats
vigie s'étant porté partie civile
syndicats partis vis j'y étais partie
civile donc le syndicat dont je suis le
secrétaire général car monsieur benalla
et monsieur kraz avait jeté l'opprobe
sur toute la profession de policier les
policiers sont régulièrement mis en en
cause dans des actions de violence
policière et là très clairement cette
vidéo qui avait fait le buzz le 1er mai
au soir à tournai largement et ce
n'était pas du tout des violences
policières c'était des violences
élyséenne et il ya eu un silence très
coupable de l'elysée qui était au
courant de ces faits à de toute la
hiérarchie policière et donc il était
important pour défendre tous les
policiers qui risquent leur vie au
quotidien de qu'il ne soit pas mise en
cause dans cette dans cette affaire
aujourd'hui il ya plein de responsables
de cette situation qu'ils ne sont pas là
nous avons monsieur macron qu'avait dit
qu'il était le seul responsable de cette
affaire d'état même pas entendu même pas
venu dire un mot donc nous avons des
politiques qui sont très forts en
paroles en actes il n'y a plus personne
il est facile de fanfaronner dans un
comité de soutien protéger de ses gardes
du corps quand il s'agit d'aller
s'expliquer faire de la pédagogie n'y a
plus personne il ya toutes les personnes
aussi de la république en marche qui ont
diffusé des vidéos de surveillance de la
ville de paris qui ne sont pas venus ici
s'expliquer non plus avec les préjudices
que ça engendre est à noter le ton très
sévère du délibéré lu par la présidente
au sujet d' alexandre benalla elle a
évoqué son sentiment d'impunité de
toute-puissance son mépris affiché de la
justice à la blâmer son refus d'admettre
sa responsabilité ses nombreux mensonges
le fait qu'il est abusé un chef de
cabinet pour obtenir un passeport de
service alexandre pénale est parti sans
faire de déclaration on en vient à cet
hommage ce matin trois ans après le
drame de la rue d'aubagne à marseille
huit personnes avaient trouvé la mort
dans l'effondrement de leur immeuble au
numéro 63 et 65 les habitants du
quartier et des membres d'associations
se sont sont venus commémorer leur
mémoire mais aussi dénoncer le
mal-logement à marseille on voit cela vk
emilie google et isabelle feria
flambeau et portraits de victimes à la
main ils se sont réunis pour rendre
hommage à ceux qui étaient leurs voisins
ou encore leurs proches il ya trois ans
huit habitants trouvé la mort dans
l'effondrement de leur immeuble vétuste
à 9h05 précise huit minutes de silence
ont été observées en leur mémoire
du 63 et 65 rue d'aubagne il ne reste
plus qu'une ruine surnommée la dent
creuse elle témoigne d'une tragédie qui
aurait pu être évité et dont les
responsabilités n'ont pas encore été
définis comme l'expliquent ses membres
du collectif du 5 novembre 2018 les
habitants a appelé la mairie en disant
qu'il y avait un problème structurel
on les a évacués pendant quelques heures
on leur a dit qu'on les a rappelés et on
leur a dit que c'était réglé donc oui on
aurait pu éviter puisque on aurait dû
fermer cet immeuble c2 imams d'ailleurs
et reloger les gens directement quoi il
ya toujours une douleur importante
il y a toujours des responsabilités qui
sont à établir et un des messages des
familles c'est aussi ça c'est de dire à
quand à quand les personnes qui sont
responsables de ces morts seront seront
jugés donc il ya une forte attente de ce
côté là la crise du mal logement se
poursuit dans la cité phocéenne
d'après le collectif du 5 novembre
chaque mois à marseille une trentaine
d'évacuation ont lieu pour cause de
vétusté
pour la nouvelle municipalité
le problème est politique
nous n'avons toujours pas de plan local
de l'habitat
donc c'est très difficile d'arriver à à
se baser là dessus mais l'habitat
indigne et tout ce que nous vivons ici
est aussi une conséquence directe de
cette politique voulue pendant des
décennies de non production de logement
social à marseille notamment dans
certains quartiers pour venir en aide
aux locataires lorsque les propriétaires
n'effectue pas les travaux de
sécurisation nécessaire la ville a voté
une enveloppe de 48 millions d'euros
pour quatre ans selon un rapport
commandé par le gouvernement
cent mille personnes vivent dans
quarante mille taudis à marseille autre
drame celui du naufrage du bugaled
breizh le 15 janvier 2004 cinq marins
français avaient péri dans le naufrage
de leur bateau au large des cornouailles
est la justice britannique a conclu à un
accident de pêche conclusions rendues
cinq ans après le non lieu définitif
rendu en france la thèse de l'accrochage
avec un sous-marin défendue par les
familles des victimes a donc été écartée
boris johnson tire la corde vers vie
quitte à faire enrager à bruxelles dans
la ligne de mire du premier ministre
britannique l'irlande du nord il dénonce
l'accord maintenant à la province au
sein de l'union européenne et les
problèmes d'approvisionnement qui en
découlent selon londres à son
gouvernement menace de suspendre cet
accord en déclenchant l'article 16 es si
cela devait arriver bruxelles averti
face aux graves conséquences d'une telle
décision écoutez le vice président de la
commission européenne
vilotte et barjols écosystèmes
nous entendons beaucoup parler de
l'article 16 en ce moment il ne fait
aucun doute que le déclenchement de
l'article 16 pour demander la
renégociation du protocole aurait de
graves conséquences graves pour
l'irlande du nord car cela conduirait à
l'instabilité et à l'imprévisibilité et
grave aussi pour les relations entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni en
général car cela signifierait un rejet
des efforts de l'union européenne pour
trouver une solution consensuelle à la
mise en oeuvre du protocole
oct aps la direction à l'école où se
poursuit la coop 26 jusqu'au 12 novembre
sur fond de grogne toujours l es jeunes
militants écologistes ont fait entendre
leur voix à commencer par à l'icône
greta sonberg l'icône des jeunes
écologistes pour elle à ce rendez vous
est un échec et la coop 26 n'aura pas
d'impact selon avant le rassemblement
prévu à demain d'une large coalition
d'organisations ils étaient des milliers
à se rassembler aujourd'hui pour
dénoncer l'inaction des dirigeants
mondiaux écouter ses réactions
j'ai vécu trois cyclones majeurs j'ai vu
les inondations entrer dans notre maison
et j'ai ramassé la boue j'ai dit ce
matin que je me souvenais de l'odeur de
la bouffe qui vous arrive aux genoux
parce que c'est la réalité des
inondations elle laisse derrière elle
des résidus et je sais ce que c'est que
de ramasser ça dans les maisons c'est
juste la réalité vécue par les jeunes
les jeunes qui vivent dans des
communautés vulnérables climat
je pense que bien souvent lorsque nous
pensons globalement aux changements
climatiques
nous pensons à des impacts sévère dans
le futur comme un futur dystopique mais
pour les îles c'est le présent que nous
vivons en ce moment
les organisateurs de la coupe 26 ne sont
pas inutiles car ils permettent que cela
se produise ils permettent à la société
civile de se réunir ils permettent aux
voix indigènes d'être entendu aux voix
du sud mais je ne pense pas que les
dirigeants mondiaux qui discutent soit
d'une quelconque utilité parce qu'ils ne
font que dire ce qu'ils disent depuis
des décennies c'est à dire uniquement
des fausses promesses sur des objectifs
soit disant ambitieux mais qui sont en
fait plein de failles donc pour eux ce
n'est pas utile c'est juste du
greenwashing
des manifestations marches la coop 26
nécessaire selon octave deauville et
porte parole du mouvement étudiant comac
de l'université libre de bruxelles on
écoute
la coupe vent elle banques dont 10
filles au bon moment
l'état met des pelotons vraiment pas du
tout à la hauteur du défi climatique
dont on a besoin
et effectivement si on est parti comme
ça on va pas repartir et
qui est important est que même en
triplant sont pas interrompus et la
cop16 elle
elle n'a pas l'air d'aller dans la bonne
direction la mobilisation les
manifestations étaient sa marque a un
impact et s'est attaqué aujourd'hui
qu'il preuve on n'y arrive pas on
n'arrivera pas demain et pour soi qu'on
peut constituer à taux fixe et à
décourager et qu'on avance et tacle
toute façon on n'a pas le choix et on a
besoin d'un grand son de trompe enfin
tourner toutes les têtes
le département d'état américain a validé
ce jeudi un contrat de vente d'armes à
destination de l'arabie saoudite le
premier depuis l'accession de joe biden
à la maison blanche pour en parler on va
retrouver tout de suite notre
correspondant à washington thomas boni
thomas bonsoir alors sur quoi portent ce
contrat entre washington et ryad
il s'agit d'un contrat d'armement de 650
millions de dollars qui a été validé par
la diplomatie américaine il s'agit
notamment de 280 missiles de moyenne
portée de type erp erp ayem 120 c'est
une vente justifiée par le pentagone par
une augmentation des attaques
transfrontalières contre l'arabie
saoudite écouter
cette vente proposée soutiendra la
politique étrangère des états unis et la
sécurité nationale américaine en aidant
à améliorer la sécurité d'un pays ami
qui continue d'être une force importante
pour le progrès économique et politique
au moyen-orient
si ce contrat n'est pas invalidée par le
congrès alors il s'agira de la première
vente d'armes de l'administration baden
à destination de l'arabie saoudite
pourtant l'une des premières mesures
géopolitique de joe biden lorsqu'il est
arrivé à la maison blanche a été de
revoir la doctrine en vigueur concernant
ces contrats passés avec ryad on peut
aussi se souvenir qu'en 2019 lors de la
primaire démocrate joe biden avait
indiqué vouloir faire de mohamed ben
salman un paria et donc au mois de
février 2021 lors de son premier
discours au département d'état américain
en tant que président des états unis
voici la tonalité qui était employé par
joe biden pour parler de la guerre au
yémen
cette guerre doit cesser et pour
souligner notre détermination nous
mettons fin à tout soutien américain aux
opérations offensives dans la guerre au
yémen y compris aux ventes d'armes alors
la précision est important que les états
unis mettent fin au soutien pour les
opérations offensives pas de problème en
revanche pour continuer à livrer du
matériel à des fins à défensive et
d'ailleurs dans le contrat qui vient
d'être validé par la diplomatie
américaine il ya une précision pour
expliquer que ces missiles doivent
servir pour la défense aérienne de
l'arabie saoudite mais en aucun cas ne
doivent être utilisés sur des cibles au
sol autres justifications apportées par
le pentagone notamment celle de protéger
les troupes américaines qui sont
déployés dans des bases en arabie
saoudite mais cette nuance ne suffit pas
à éteindre les critiques de certains qui
voient une trahison finalement de la
parole de joe biden lui qui avait déjà
essuyé des critiques similaires
lorsqu'il avait décidé de ne pas tenir
mohamed ben salman comme responsable du
meurtre du journaliste jamal khashoggi
en dépit à des informations délivrées
par la cia en ce sens on peut aussi
rappeler qu'au mois de septembre dernier
déjà washington avait approuvé un
contrat de 500 millions de dollars pour
la maintenance d'hélicoptères de combat
là encore en arabie saoudite
beaucoup avaient souligné à l'époque le
fait que ces appareils étaient très
sûrement très probablement utilisé pour
des opérations offensives menées par
l'arabie saoudite au yémen c'est donc
une forme d'hypocrisie qui est dénoncée
concernant la position de joe biden par
rapport à l'arabie saoudite lui qui
avait fait la promesse de la rupture
avec la politique menée en son temps par
donald trump il suit finalement sur ce
sujet les pas de son prédécesseur
beaucoup avouent un tome abonnés pour
tous ces précisions en direct depuis
washington
on en vient à la crise au au soudan
depuis le putsch du 25 octobre le
conseil des droits de l'homme a demandé
le retour des civils au pouvoir il s'est
réuni en urgence aujourd'hui pour voter
une résolution dans ce sens à l'instance
onusienne condamne également la
détention jugées injustes du premier
ministre à dallas and docks et la
libération immédiate de tous les détenus
arbitraire et put et michelle bachelet
la haut commissaire aux droits de
l'homme on écoute tout de suite
cette prise de pouvoir de l'armée trahi
la révolution courageuse et inspirante
de 2019 elle contrevient à la fois au
droit international à celui des droits
de l'homme ainsi qu'aux propre document
constitutionnel du pays
et les autres documents fondateurs de la
transition
j'exhorte les chefs militaires
soudanais-- leur soutien à se retirer
afin de permettre au pays de retrouver
la voie du progrès vers des réformes
institutionnelles et légal
la formation d'une alliance de neuf
groupes rebelles contre le premier
ministre éthiopien a bien admettre
depuis washington une alliance formée
notamment par des combattants du tplf le
front de libération du peuple du tigré
en guerre avec les forces
gouvernementales depuis plus d'un an à
l'intention est de renverser le pouvoir
en place lors de la signature de cette
alliance baptisée front uni des forces
fédéralistes et confédéraliste
éthiopienne plusieurs représentants de
ces groupes se sont exprimés ils ont
appelé elles les éthiopiens à s'unir
dans leur combat contre le gouvernement
d' habiller hammett
par le front uni des forces fédéralistes
et confédéraliste éthiopienne le 5
novembre 2021 nous les forces
fédéralistes et confédéraliste
d'ethiopie avons le plaisir d'annoncer
la création d'un front le front uni des
forces fédéralistes et confédéraliste
éthiopienne
ce que nous allons faire quelle est la
limite il n'y a pas de limite pour nous
parce que le régime comme vous le savez
tous essayent de mobiliser des millions
de personnes pour se battre contre nous
tous quand je parle de personnes je ne
parle pas de l'armée l'intention est de
mobiliser des millions d'agriculteurs
pour conduire la nation vers un terrible
bain de sang donc sans aucun doute nous
allons nous défendre et nous allons
essayer de nous débarrasser du
gouvernement à bille
notre message aux éthiopiens vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous battre pour le
gouvernement qui vous ramènera à l'
esclavage qui vous ramènera à la
domination à la peur ceci est une
liberté vous tous nous vous appelons à
vous unir avec all of you
we are calling you to united
en tunisie un ancien président visé par
un mandat
international
moncef marzouki accusé d'avoir porté
atteinte aux intérêts nationaux on lui
reproche a notamment des propos tenus
sur des médias contre le coup de force
du président kaïs aed ont fait le point
avec notre correspondant à tunis bassem
chipie
c'est une première dans l'histoire de la
justice tunisienne le bureau
d'information du tribunal de première
instance de tunis a annoncé hier
l'émission d'un mandat d'amener
international contre monde cf marzouki
premier président de la république
tunisienne post ben ali en cause des
propos tenus lors d'une intervention
télévisée le 12 octobre dernier sur le
plateau de france 24 l'ancien opposant
de benali se félicitait d'avoir oeuvré
au report du sommet de la francophonie
moncef marzouki en avait profité pour
rappeler les autorités françaises a
rejeté tout soutien à kaïs ayed qui
selon lui auraient comploté contre la
révolution de 2011 est aboli la
constitution par la mise en place de
mesures exceptionnelles furieux le 15
octobre dernier l'actuel locataire du
palais de carthage avaient ordonné au
cours d'une réunion du conseil des
ministres l'ouverture d'une enquête
judiciaire contre ceux qui portent
atteinte aux intérêts fondamentaux de la
tunisie depuis l étranger et complotent
contre la sûreté de l'état selon le
porte-parole de la cour d'appel de tunis
une enquête a été ouverte contre moncef
marzouki par ordonnance de la ministre
de la justice et par ordre du procureur
de la république près le tribunal de
première instance de tunis depuis le
coup de force du président sayed le 25
juillet dernier moncef marzouki qui
réside actuellement en france a
multiplié les interventions sur les
chaînes de télévision notamment france
24 et al jazeera pour appeler à la
destitution de celui qu'il qualifie de
putschistes ou encore de dictateurs
longtemps connu comme l'un des opposants
historiques de l'ancien président zine
el-abidine ben ali moncef marzouki
symbolisait le combat pour la démocratie
en tunisie avant de voir son image
entachée par son rapprochement avec le
parti d'inspiration islamiste ennahda
moncef marzouki qui s'est vu retirer son
passeport diplomatique est devenu en
l'espace d'un mois l'un des ennemis de
la tunisie aux yeux de l'actuel homme
fort de tunis et le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref à et en images en
irak à bagdad des heurts entre partisans
pro iran il forces de sécurité
aujourd'hui les affrontements qui
interviennent à la suite de l'annoncé
des résultats préliminaires des
législatives à des groupes
paramilitaires en colère ont tenté de
pénétrer dans le quartier des
institutions politiques de la capitale
mais ont été repoussés par les forces de
l'ordre depuis trois semaines maintenant
est les manifestations se multiplient
dans le pays a les contestataires
dénoncent une fraude électorale et
demande un recomptage des fois
new delhi enveloppée d'un épais
brouillard toxiques au lendemain de la
traditionnelle fête de diwali cette fête
hindoue qui est célébrée avec des lampes
à huile et des bougies et qui brûlent
toute la nuit dans les zones les plus
polluées le niveau moyen de particules
nocives a dépassé 400 selon l'indicé de
qualité de l'air il est quinze fois
supérieur à la limite quotidienne de
sécurité fixées par l' oms
en indonésie à l'est de l'île de java
des pluies diluviennes se sont abattues
ce jeudi provoquant une crue soudaine le
bilan est actuellement de six morts et
trois portées disparues les opérations
de secours ont été compliqués par à des
routes bloquées des pannes de courant et
des débris et une boue épaisse
[Musique]
le parquet national financiers en france
a ouvert mi juin une enquête sur une
possible affaire de trafic d'influencé
dans le rachat de suez part à veolia a
parmi les mises en cause alexis kohler
le secrétaire général de l'elysée ainsi
que des responsables de véolia et dungey
on voit cela avec estelle fâche créer un
champion mondial de la transformation
écologique c'est l'ambition du groupe
veolia à travers son au pea sur son
rival suez déjà propriétaire de 29,9
pour cent de suez depuis octobre 2020
veolia a lancé une opération publique
d'achat en juillet dernier afin
d'acquérir les 70 1 % restants la
transaction devrait être soldées en
janvier prochain mais tout pourrait ne
pas se passer comme prévu car l'union
syndicale du groupe suez a déposé
plainte le 22 avril dernier auprès du
parquet national financiers pour des
faits de trafic d'influencé
elle dénonce une opération calculé au
plus haut sommet de l'état et demande sa
suspension immédiate loupé à hostile de
veolia en verre suez n'obéit à aucune
logique économique ou industrielle
il apparaît aujourd'hui que cet opéra ne
serait que le fruit de décisions prises
et favoriser au plus haut sommet de
l'état pour dépecer le géant français
des services environnementaux au seul
profit de quelques-uns les syndicats
soupçonnent plus particulièrement le
secrétaire général de l'elysée alexis
kohler le pdg de veolia le président du
conseil d'administration d' angie et le
pdg du fonds d'investissement méridiam
de s'être entendues sur la fusion dans
leur plainte selon la lfp les syndicats
citent plusieurs réunions impliquant le
gouvernement il cite aussi
l'intervention d' alexis kohler en
octobre 2020 auprès de représentants
syndicaux l' enquête a été confiée à
l'office central de lutte contre la
corruption et les infractions
financières et fiscales une première
victoire pour les syndicats on ne peut
que se réjouir que la plainte des
syndicats était prise au sérieux par le
pnf qui ouvre une enquête cette enquête
doit faire la lumière sur les collusions
entre le monde politique et le monde des
affaires c'est malheureusement une
spécificité française de l'autre côté
veolia meridiam et angie se refuse à
tout commentaire quant à alexis colère
il est déjà visé par une information
judiciaire dans la sphère des chantiers
navals de saint nazaire pour prise
illégale d'intérêt trafic d'influencé et
défauts de déclaration à la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique il est soupçonné d'avoir caché
ses liens familiaux avec des cadres de
l'entreprise de msc alors qu'il aurait
favorisé l'entreprise dans des décisions
engageant de l'argent public sous la
houlette d'un emmanuel macron à leur
ministre de l'économie et c'est la fin
de cette édition merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi on va se retrouver dans une
trentaine de minutes rester avec mon
super père ans
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]